today we're going to focus on an endgame
concept known as shouldering so can
anybody tell me what they think
shouldering is in the end game so when
the Kings are making sure that the other
one doesn't come in to play so you can
think about it more or less in like a
soccer match I know it's not the most
popular sport here but shouldering and
soccers you know when they use the
shoulders and they're trying to get the
other guy out of balance right they're
both going for the same square or the
ball but only one of them can get there
right so the idea of shouldering entrust
is that one of the sides is going to try
to accomplish its goal while making sure
that the opponent doesn't do the same so
we got this position and it's white to
move it'll be white to move on most
examples I believe and let's analyze
real quick what's going on
it's white butter is black butter yes
WAIS why it better all right are you
sure do you calculate okay you're wrong
there's a and games are very tricky
because they sometimes seem like your
visual understanding should be enough to
know what's going on in a position but
that's not always necessarily true in
chess you gotta rely on calculation and
it's mostly important in any games and
games are it's very difficult for you to
go in general principles where the
material is so reduced usually there's a
correct answer so let's try out your
theory that you get my pawn right that's
your theory we're going to go one right
one bum bum bum bum bum bum and bam Zook
song so white has to move he loses
control of her b6 and therefore is a
lost endgame right yes agreed alright so
I'm going to ask again what's going on
in the same game yes
luck is not me this will be a very bad
example but well it does seem like
blacks winning right
I mean if yes well well one second if we
count the squares black wins all the
races right so it seems like this is
just over yeah did you have a question
how okay so what we'll go back to our
endgame basics and if there's an endgame
basics class that should be covered what
are the key squares of a b7 pawn which
means what is the square that the black
King needs to control in order to say
that this is already a win if the King
lands in which square is this a winning
endgame so let's remove this pawn from
your use your imagination use your
imagination and remove the b6 pawn from
existence right which square does this
King have to be in to guarantee victory
b5 is one of the key squares there's
actually three yes and
one doesn't belong with the others yes
if the king controls or is in a5 b5 or
c5 once the pawn on d6 is removed then
it is a winning game game this is
already known right this is just basic
chest and game theory principles but it
does seem like if I get my king in front
of the point that I should be able to
draw right so that's your idea right
bring the king so how can we do this yes
let's go King g4 or I'm going to go king
c2
therefore we're working d3 yes qe5 I'm
looking c4
and you guys are now subject to what's
called shouldering let's try that again
if I played ass black King b2 King f4
King b3 Guinea for King before King G
for King B Phi King c3 takes King before
I get the opposition and the same game
is a draw as black will never be able to
control a 5v5 or c5 this is a known draw
because White has the opposition in this
case right however I didn't let you do
that I used my king let's go back and
shouldered yours away so inches this is
not a longer distance than this for
purposes of King movement right they
both take the exact same amount of Tempe
but with the let's use a different color
arrow with the green path I'm able to at
the same time shoulder the King out the
White King cannot come into action does
that make sense to everybody
so here why it's losing because I cannot
get to the key square which is b4 I need
to land on b4 when my opponent takes the
pawn that's the premise of the situation
when black takes on b6 my King needs to
land on before immediately after right
so this looks lost however there is a
solution
Genji three I'll go king c2
but all right okay g3 sorry it's been a
long day
Kingsley - King F - our King D three
eewan King c4 can be 5 again it's the
same rule this path is just as long as
this path but by going through the
bottom of the board I eluded the
opponent's king influence therefore the
king couldn't shoulder me out the King
was unable to keep me at bay because at
some point it has to go forward it can't
keep shouldering me out forever it has
to go forward at some point which means
that in this position after king one I
with every single move moved to left
with my king whereas in this position
when I started with King g4 notice that
there comes a point in time where I can
no longer move to the left since we know
already that going up loses right is
this example clear to everybody right so
this is a draw actually it's a it's a
nice little complicated situation
considering that there's only you know
two kings and two pawns but it's a draw
and there's only one way to achieve it
for white if you play anything but King
g3 you are immediately losing all right
let's hope this works
yes excellent so now we're going to see
a different example again only two pawns
in the position and only two kings and
yet it's not exactly a very simple
solution first thing we always have to
do is calculate so let's try to go for
the pawn on b7 do some mental
calculation and tell me what happens if
I go for the opponent b7 how's the game
end
hmm white wins all right we have a draw
split jury here a draw as your
calculator are you guessing
okay very good at least he's honest yeah
let's try it up King here King here King
here come here come here come here
thank you're in here now it looks like a
drum if I go a four he goes King here
right that looks pretty drawers to me
can I improve maybe here I can go a four
and not really he goes King c4 I taking
b4 still a draw right maybe instead of
taking the point I advance this one well
no he just goes King before now looks
like a draw yeah yes
okay
all right let's try a 4qf to learn a
five so this is kind of same idea of
shouldering right now we already know
what black should do here yes a king F
three goes into the shouldering at
anyone okay let's try can see four just
on time right one time so still a drop
yeah so if you start with a four I go
king f2 and on a five I go under king e1
to avoid the shouldering right so this
is the drop can you two is actually the
only winning try you need to is
excellent because I'm going to use the
fact that the King has no useful moves
to improve my position how could I
improve my position compared to what it
was at the beginning what would be an
improvement the pawn can go all the way
to a5 and only then do I bring my king
closer so for example if I play the move
King G - what would I play yes now you
go away for notice what the King doesn't
have a useful move it cannot come closer
it doesn't matter if it's in the third
rank or the first rank it cannot come
closer
it's shouldered by the opponent King so
for example King here now what do I do
can you three I think in these three
also works but why give him the
opportunity where I can go King III and
shoulder him out again and the son game
is now quite easily winning I mean you
don't even have to calculate too hard I
go to b6 take the phone and then go
Asics immediately afterwards yes
everybody clear with that let's go Kim
g4 here here waiting yeah
no because I'm just going to stay on b7
right I don't have to go to a a time
trap myself I'm just going to take on b7
and the iPhone just much marches forward
the a pawn is a draw as long as this
King is on c8 but if it's not on c8 then
it's shouldered out again back to the
shouldering stuff right the king is
shouldering out your opponent
you cannot come closer cool everybody
clear with this and then yes
all right cool let's go to the next
example we have this strange position
we're going to be playing as black
because if we play us white this is
Purdy's so it's black to play right and
obviously you're worse
you got one pawn which is your last
remaining hope and guys got a rook and
he's got a rope that's already behind
the pawn and the Kings coming in and
you're still thinking well what's for
dinner right I mean this is hopeless
looks pretty bad but let's try to use
what we've learned today to figure out
if black has any hope in this position
increase correct yeah let's try the
direct approach
alright first III Kim c5 yes there are
some nari Slav helpful numbers up here
that tell you which direction this is
facing ah King f3 King D for e2 King D 3
right wins one time and I don't see
anything else but the move King III is
quite clever it looks stupid because it
puts the King in front of the pawn which
is very logical considering that the
pawn
well I wants to go forward with the King
on the way it seems difficult to achieve
this but in this specific scenario the
King belongs on e3 because it must
shoulder out the opponent the Kingdom b6
wants to come closer to the action yes
exactly
yeah I mean I can always take the pawn
with the rook if I feel like I don't
want to try and then okay that's always
yeah draw so yeah blacks playing for a
draw and you have to be very careful
right because he loses the last bone
it's over but King III is correct it
loses a temple but gains a lot of
control in this games the King on b6
cannot come closer to the action if I
for example play king c5 I have king d3
now see how the King can't it can go in
and I'm just trying to play 3e - King D
2 and push my pawn
not too hard now you guys can play
around with the same game as long as you
want but it's a drop ok so yeah you can
give me check and I'll go King c3 or you
can try going through the side but it
doesn't matter the same game is a draw
you might need to use another promotion
trick I don't remember
everybody knows on under promotion is
under promotion is when you promote to
something that is not a queen I think
you need it in this case but I don't
really remember it to because I think
when this position arises - if I go you
know I can go you one there's some
problems yeah
now you don't you don't even need under
promotion here if I go on the other side
and set here here here you're here check
here here then I do need the under
promotion right if I promote to the
Queen I obviously lose to checkmate but
I can promote to actually don't know how
you do that now there you go ah nope
probably but that that sounds painful I
don't know want to do that you promote
to at night and it's check okay and then
the the horsey is the tax the king the
King moves and then eventually it's a
draw okay like the rook cannot beat the
knight that that's a no fact unless the
Knights trap thus it is but since it's
only one and has many squares so that's
a known drug yes agreed it's a knife
promotes tonight and it's a drug
okay cool so there's another case of
shouldering we see it mainly in rock n
game sending King and pawn and games but
there are most ten games at least in
some way or shape or form well you use
your King in order to dominate your
opponents in this case it's more
important to dominate your opponent's
king with my own then it is to push the
pawn as quickly as possible so King III
is correct in this situation alright so
we're going to now think about this the
center game this is an old composition
to serve as anybody seen this one before
so for the confused audience the pawn is
on d5 and it's going that way
Valley okay going down so it's white to
move and currently my rooks under attack
right so this is a ready study from 1928
and we're going to sit and think how
this white win obviously drawing is
quite easy I just grab my rope I take
the pawn and then we all go home but
what I'm going to try to win yes
Rudy you on alright d4 okay
now what should I play it's striking you
far
wedding right pretty easy dumb
grandmaster with the silly puzzles now
there's some better alternative here for
black yes can be five yes arrghh d2y
roti - we go thank you too
ah you're down a temple compared to the
other problem right or the other line
because you played rugby - now the rook
has to move away well okay but this is
obviously a draw right okay - King you
wanna promote next move so suddenly this
is tricky yeah
chide these forces the King can't get
which king ah well cd4 then yes
three
I wonder what I'm going to play I'm
going to go ahead and say t2
and this is quite obviously a draw right
yeah okay draw
hi-yah what to do
let's see okay for D for
come on guys there's only one rock in
one pond how hard can this be
yes okay five
g6
all right
where he's working five
I think this dress I think this dress
and I think this dress so I'm going to
go with the this one I think it looks
like the easiest why not help the pawn
out looks like you need to hand no
progress right too fast the pawn and
King do was too fast what ends up
happening to White's King in every
single scenario yes it's getting
shouldered out by the opponent King
you have to elude the guy
my book
three we get to the far making up the
black circle okay
2466 hi
warm Buchanan's legal no progress
come on guys
one met different
what we're trying to get the king away
huh so let's try let's try for black if
I go king f4 what happens check here it
doesn't seem like it helps me because
unfortunately now the rooks on the wrong
square it's going to get attacked when I
go to t2 whenever black pushes all the
way to d2 it's under attack it gains a
temple ha what to do what to do man next
time I'm gonna bring may be easier
puzzles with less pieces
yes
all right d4
well that's a little illegal I don't
know where this gigs going there's
nothing on h8 alright so now comes the
solution there's actually two solutions
to this problem which makes it a bad
composition but I was trying to figure
out well you guys were like making up
moves why the second version works and I
have to admit that I don't remember I
remember the simpler version both roopd
100d to win and I'll show you why
route D 2 wins because that's the most
instructive but I don't remember why I
wrote D 1 wins
so after rook t1 sorry I wrecked it to D
for the crack movies rook D 1 because I
need to outflank the opponent King I
need for him to move to define where
it's going if he goes Kimmy for came
here yes
d3 king here here come here
winning right and if he goes king defy
what do I play you know 6 and that's the
first thing I said today stop trusting
your intuition calculate you got a
calculating this hanging it's very
important wise King f6 fail
because I shoulder you off with Keaney
for certainly again the king is not able
to come back into the game yes well rug
did to doesn't quite work because when I
go Keaney for I'll be able to win a
temple once I play King III right so
what do I play
yes very good
King d7 remember I'm waiting for him to
define which side of the pony is going
to go into and I'm going to go on the
opposite so we already know that Keaney
for loses to King d6 by right we already
saw this everybody agree by geometric
properties of chest we know that King
c-4 must also lose to King D 6 and if he
goes king c5 then I go King e6 if he
goes King e5 if I go King c6 clear now
I'm trying to figure and try to remember
why I know that root D 1 also wins but I
figure why so that'll be the next lesson
but the clearest way is roopd 2 and on
d4 root D 1 we lose a temple let us
remind you of any concept and trust
you've learned there's opposition that's
why I'm losing a temple because I want
the opposition it's not just about pawn
and games opposition happens in many
cases in this case blacks in Zhuge zone
alright next problem
first let me remember who is the move
yeah it's black the move in this
position
so things are looking a little bad for
black here right now the pawn on g6 yes
you go kh2 maybe oh that's what's that's
what's bothering me there you go all
right there you go much better
all right ah so we can try king h2 then
I take uh-huh you have to
oh no no stalemate on the next move
right no just get Kim g3 it's a known
trick this on stalemates you and after
king g1 i move my rope pretty much
anywhere and you cannot Queen because I
check made you and if you make if you
make a horsey like we did in the other
scenario there's a big difference it's
trapped after I play King x3 and I would
show you except I forgot how to do this
settings for settings what is this
go away settings oh here
anybody remember this is just high and
use it yeah yeah perfect really you need
to do all this okay I just wanted to
firm up to a night that's all I wanted
to do okay night perfect
yay a horsey all right so now after King
of three there's kind of a significant
difference the knight doesn't have any
squares on this side of the board to go
to which will make it an easy draw qg3
and ninety three immediately loses king
f1 immediately loses and night have two
losses pretty trivially to check on a1
right so therefore this was
unfortunately not a good defense yes
no okay the same kind of thing happens
against h2 check King h3 and now what
should I play us white right in f3 you
see ya King f2 not King f3 because this
is check don't do that
but King f2 very good now if I promote
to a queen check and I win the Queen for
free well if you promote to a knight
again the same idea that after King f3
your knight is trapped this one is a
little bit more elaborate on winning the
night but it's not too difficult you go
King eh to check King here and I think
after rook was the winning move here I
have to lose a temple yeah you go rook
to e1 King here and I believe it's rook
anywhere and the knight is lost in a
couple of moves it cannot defend the
King very well something like this what
matters is this is losing and going back
to shouldering let's figure out then
what to do here
tg4 I take no your Kings definitely
going somewhere I'm not sure he wants to
go that place but it's going somewhere
yes
I mean after cute it's already loosing
right a blue stuff was the point
yeah it's for out way take now I'm going
to here
doesn't seem too different
g5 okay I think not entirely sure that
it improved your position we don't have
the luxury I think of wasting a temple
well since you guys tried King H - King
H for King g4 and h2 and even g5
yes 15 G - there is no other legal move
in this position
kingi team is correct because after
check you don't go into the corner you
put you play King f1 and now the king is
shouldering the other if rook h6 what do
I play
yes very good change it
now if check I go back here here so up
so repeat so I'll be what's probably
best try here can you - maybe but notice
how that loses a crucial temple because
now I can play h2 and after check I
thinking h1 is good here yeah
King each one should be good enough and
in the previous scenario where was the
king it was on f2 where we went to g3
right winning but now it's one square
away because it had to waste that tempo
going to be 2 so this shoulder set out
wins the crucial tempo and now this is a
draw what I thinking h3 is also a draw
here making h3 no King streaking if - ok
h1 is correct alright so children making
sense
all right now we are going to go to so
where we're left with some of the
toughest so we're going to look at the
actual puzzles I have open notation so
this is square Center perfect - yes
all right so this is your shouldering
final like your final test
why to play and win all right worth
takes our 5 check and everything man
what a move it checks it takes a fun and
forces the King to move and it draws the
game after King g4 rook whatever
h5 you're like way too far away the king
is way way too far away from action and
it's going to be easily shouldered I
mean it's already it cannot go around
this King cannot go around the H pawn
because there's no ijk file see how it
took me a second to be like a we see the
og yeah there are no more files for him
to like go into so I cannot show I
cannot go out around the pond I'm easily
shouldered out
so that didn't work when we start
getting the idea of shouldering right
if King takes again King g4 is to draw
every King g5 of the draw is a draw but
I think in g4 should be good enough I
don't see why it wouldn't be kf7 is
correct
mm-hmm that's striking here
illogical
which one should we try here for a black
calculating after striking audio well fr
seems to lose weight on exactly right
the kink an outer is the pawn in case of
f4 try h5
five is next week and which ones
quarters I'll probably not play the F
pawn right I'll probably play the H bar
seems to make more sense to me
wrote g6 okay that looks good to me
uh-oh
that's a drug where do we go wrong not
so easy yeah this is a fun thing about
end games you can always actually
calculate them out the concepts are
there and it's important for you guys to
know them before you delve into
calculations and that it allows you to
consider moves that you wouldn't have
thought of before right
perhaps before this last of the king f7
would not have been the first thing you
would have think thought up in this
position but now that you're more
familiar with children you know that it
has to go around the King has to go
around in this position looking up seven
King g4 I actually don't remember this
puzzle but I was just hoping I could
figure it out
King e6 looks like it's correct h5 you
guys played king e5 here right make
sense for check f3
I wonder where you guys went wrong
here well that's at the most repetition
oh that's a supreme kind of a
unsoldering huh I wonder if King before
works in this position huh
oops I destroyed that probably there's
more than one move I didn't know that
I thought King before was only moved but
I forgot if it was absolutely forced
yaki divorce correct I what I didn't
remember is if there was other ways of
winning in this position but yes again
exactly back to the point of the puzzle
it takes the exact same amount of time
for you to get to the back rank no
matter how you do it
this is winning correct you can control
both pawns at the same time basically so
for example after h3 King III is very
obviously winning after f4 this allows
me to gain a tempo with King e4 because
if you push your pawn I can go check
blacks best try in this position is
probably kingi for King jeez five is
just amazing it's kind of the same thing
Keeney six and after age five yeah king
e5 seems to be the easiest when king d5
leads to the same thing because you can
also play King Devon the next move and I
want to say that rook h6 wins but the
important thing is that in this position
once you know the shouldering maneuver
King f7 is absolutely the only way to
win anything that's not King f7 drawers
you need to go around the King so as to
not get shouldered out this looks very
complex because there's a pawn and
calculation and stuff like that but
ultimately this is uh the same as this
puzzle you're just avoiding the
opponent's king you're bringing your
King through one in order to not get
shouldered out by your opponent in the
other you bring it so from the center
towards the Kings side instead of
straight down does that make sense early
so that's pretty much it from what I
have for my shouldering lesson since the
last puzzles a little long I hope you
guys enjoyed it and that you learned
something about shouldering and it comes
out in a lot of games special a lot of
rook end games and the nice thing about
knowing it is that you can you're
usually a lot in a big time pressure by
the time it comes and it should
instantly click that I should at least
look at the shouldering maneuvers it's a
pretty nifty thing to know about any
games alright thanks for attending